Guten Abend.
Guten Abend, Herr Doktor.
Hallo, mein Name ist NS Erdwirk.
Ich bin der für Sie zuständige Arzt in dieser Station.
Und jetzt möchte ich mit Ihnen das Anämpfelsgespräch durchführen.
Ja.
Und bevor wir anfangen, müssen wir Ihre persönliche Daten aufnehmen.
Ja, natürlich.
Zählfisierung, ja, super.
Und wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Klaus Fischer.
Klaus Fischer.
Herr Fischolder.
Herr Fischer, können Sie Ihre Vor- und Nachnamen buchstabieren?
Ja, Klaus mit K, L, A, U, S.
Und Fischer mit F, I, S, C, H, E, R.
Herr Fischer, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin jetzt 50 Jahre alt geworden dieses Jahr.
50.
Wann sind Sie genau gebaut?
14. Juli 1973.
43.
73.
73, ja.
Herr Fischer, wie groß sind Sie?
Um ungefähr 1,85 m war ich mal, aber vielleicht ein bisschen kleiner geworden ist.
1,85 m, okay.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Um ungefähr 75 kg.
75 kg.
Alles klar.
Herr Fischer, was schützt Sie zu uns?
Herr Doktor, ich habe Bauchschmerzen.
Seit einer Woche etwa habe ich diese Bauchschmerzen.
Seit einer Woche?
Ungefähr, ja.
Und diesen, ja, Komm- und Genes, die sehen ich immer gleich,
aber warum ich jetzt heute gekommen bin,
weil ich heute auch einmal erbrechen musste,
da meine ich, dass auch ein bisschen Blut dabei war,
ein älteres Blut.
Blutige Erbrochen.
Also es war so wie dunke Frauen.
Dunke Frauen, alles klar.
Sie haben nur einmal erbrochen.
Ja, nur einmal.
Mit Blutig.
Also ich denke, dass es so Blut war, ja.
Okay, alles klar.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie leiden Unterbauchschmerzen seit einer Woche?
Ja.
Und wo sind die Schmerzen genau?
Unser Bauch?
In der Mitte würde ich sagen.
In der Mitte?
Manchmal aber auch so ein bisschen nach unten gehen die auch,
aber hauptsächlich in der Bauchmitte würde ich sagen.
Okay.
Können Sie sagen, dass die Schmerzen in die Untenbauch ausgetragen?
Bisschen, ja, kann man das sagen.
Wie haben die Schmerzen begonnen, zum Beispiel für Lust,
wie hat er langsam?
So langsam haben die begonnen, ja.
Wie können Sie Ihre Schmerzen beschreiben,
zum Beispiel sind Sie dumpf, kollekartig, brennend, stehend,
oder weiter?
Ich würde sagen so dumpf bis brennend.
Und können Sie Ihre Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10 einschätzen?
Also es ist nicht immer gleich der Schmerz,
hat ich ja gesagt, aber wenn der mal stark ist, würde ich schon sagen,
so 7, 8 würde ich schon sagen, ja.
Sind Ihre Schmerzen dauerhafter oder vorbeigegehend?
Kommt gehen, ja.
Kommt Ihre Schmerzen als Attacken oder sind Sie immer da?
Manchmal weniger, manchmal mehr?
Also manchmal nachts ist es vor allem mehr, finde ich.
Okay.
Und haben die Schmerzen im Laufe der Zeit verschlechter?
Ja, es ist ein bisschen mehr geworden, ja.
Am Anfang war nicht so schlimm.
Im Laufe der Zeit verschlechter.
Okay.
Und Sie haben gesagt, wie schmeißt die Schmerzskala in den Untenbau aus?
Ja.
Und gibt es ein bestimmtes Auslöser für die Schmerzen,
zum Beispiel Essen, Trinken, Bewegung?
Also ich habe das Gefühl, dass nach dem Essen besser wird.
Nachdem es besser wird?
Ja, also wenn ich morgens dann ganz stark geschmeißen habe,
dann wenn ich ein Stück Brot esse oder wissen, was trinke,
dann wird es ein bisschen besser.
Okay.
Okay, das bedeutet, dass Essen verbessert die Schmerzen, ja.
Nun habe ich so beobachtet, ja.
Aber es geht nicht ganz weg, also es kommt dann wieder.
Und gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen verschlechter?
Schätzt nicht so, weiß ich nicht genau, kann ich es nicht so gut beurteilen?
Alles klar.
Wann dann die Schmerzen vom Ausgangspunkt, im Mittelbau,
zu einem anderen Körper teilen, oder?
Also hauptsächlich hier im mittelen Bau.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen über?
Also heute war mir halt übel einmal und dann habe ich ja noch mal sonst eigentlich weniger.
Okay, führte sie sich täglich?
Was meinen Sie?
Haben Sie Fieber?
Fieber habe ich nicht, nein, habe ich keines gemerkt.
Fieber.
Leiden Sie unter Schüttefrost oder Nachtschweiß?
Nein, habe ich keine Probleme damit.
Okay, ist klar.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit Apothezial genommen?
Also nicht wesentlich, vielleicht ist unser Kilo hoch, aber ich würde sagen,
im Weihdiskumente ist es konstant.
Okay.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben einmal Erboroschen und dann der Erboroschen
sieht ein bisschen dunkel aus.
Ja, ja.
Und, okay.
Und gibt es im Erboroschen zum Beispiel Essen oder unverdautes Essen?
Nein.
Hab ich es jetzt so nicht, ich kann nicht sagen.
Alles klar.
Und haben Sie Sortbräne?
Also ich habe immer wieder mit Sortbränen zu tun, ja, schon seit sieben Jahren.
Seit, okay, sieben Jahren.
Sieben Jahren, ja, habe ich immer mit der Sortbräne, ja.
Okay.
Und haben Sie Brustschmerzen, leiden Sie unter Brustschmerzen?
Ein Brust habe ich gar nicht schwer, nein.
Okay, leiden Sie unter Atemnot?
Auch nicht, nein.
Okay.
Trät den Schwierigkeiten beim Wasserlassen oder beim Stuhlgang auf?
Also Wasserlassen habe ich jetzt keine Probleme im Stuhlgang.
Durchfallverstoffung?
Da hatte ich mal, der Durchfall ist übertrieben,
aber ich hatte vor ein paar Tagen mal etwas so dünnere Stuhl gehabt
und da war das auch so ein bisschen von der Farbe auffällig.
Wie war der Farbe?
Dunkel, grün, so fast so.
Schwarz-grün würde ich sagen, ja.
Okay, dann das bedeutet, ihre Stuhl ist dunkel.
Aber war nur einmal der Doktor, an dem Tag.
Vielleicht hat es auch an dem Essen gelegen,
was ich am Tag vorher gegessen habe.
Ich weiß, ich habe auch so Spinat und so was gegessen
und ist auch deswegen so gewesen, ich weiß es nicht.
Okay, die Stuhl ist ein bisschen dunkel geworden,
vielleicht wegen des Essen?
Einmal, ja, also das ist einmal aufgefallen,
aber danach war wieder normal.
Okay.
Haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden in diesem Zusammenhang?
Also in diesem Zusammenhang nicht,
aber ich habe andere Baustellen bei mir,
deswegen weiß ich, ob Sie da noch etwas wissen wollen.
Also ich habe Arthrose in der Schulter und im Knie
und auch mit Rücken schmeißen habe ich immer wieder zu tun.
An vorher kranken?
Ja, okay.
Ich habe Schulterarthrose und Kniearthrose.
Okay, alles klar.
Ich hatte auch mal einen Bandscheibenvorfall gehabt,
aber das musste nicht operiert werden,
aber ich habe auch immer wieder Schmerzen im Rücken.
Ich habe auch Medikamente eingehen,
manchmal die Schmerzen zu stark sind.
Bandscheibenvorfall, seit wann leiden Sie unter?
Das war vor ungefähr 7, 8 Jahren,
da hatte ich mal Rückenschmerzen gehabt,
dann ist damals Tomografie gemacht,
dann ist das festgestellt worden,
dass Bandscheibenvorfall war.
Die Bandscheibenvorfall wurde behandelt?
Also nur Physiotherapie?
Ja.
Okay, und ich habe noch andere Fragen.
Haben Sie Probleme, ein oder durchzuschlafen?
Also in der letzten Woche war ich nachts häufiger auf,
wegen Schmerzen.
Okay, vorher aber nicht.
Die Wachen nachts an Schmerzen auf, ja?
Ja, das ist schon vorgekommen, ja.
Okay, und Treibels ist kurz?
Eigentlich nicht, nein.
Trinken Sie genug, was war?
Ja, ich trink genug, was ich glaube.
Gut, okay.
Sind bei Ihnen Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten bekannt?
Allergien habe ich keinen, nein.
Okay, raufen Sie, Herr Fischer?
Ja, ich raufe.
Wie viele Sekarate raufen Sie täglich?
Also 15 Stück vielleicht.
Seit wann raufen Sie?
30 Jahre, bestimmt schon.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Also nicht viel, 1-2 Bier pro Tag vielleicht.
Vielleicht Bier, ja?
Ja, pro Tag.
Ja, es scheint ein bisschen mehr.
Nein, so.
Was meinen Sie?
Ja, es wäre gesünder, wenn Sie weniger Alkohol trinken könnten.
Ja, zum Essen halt, ja?
Darf ich Sie fragen, ob Sie einen Kontakt mit Drogen haben?
Drogen haben, nehme ich keinen, nein.
Okay, alles klar.
Jetzt würde ich nach Ihrer Vorgeschichte wiederfragen.
Wie viele Kinder haben Sie vorhin in der Krankenhung?
Zum Beispiel die Zuckerkrankheit, die Tochterung usw.
Zucker habe ich nicht, die Tochterung habe ich auch nicht.
Bei mir sind mal Galensteine festgestellt worden,
aber Doktor gesagt, ich soll es...
Wann wurde diese Diagnose gestellt?
Also auch vor knapp 8, 9 Jahren ungefähr, ja.
Vor 9 Jahren, ja.
Und würden Sie behandelnd?
Nein, der Doktor meint, das muss man nicht behandeln,
dann kann man so beobachten, dass wäre nichts, was man behandeln müsste.
Okay.
Besuchen Sie regelmäßig dafür?
Zum Haushalt?
Eigentlich nicht, nein.
Okay.
Gibt es noch andere Erkrankungen?
Nur diese Schulteradros und diese Kreatur.
Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Als Kind. Den Daumen.
Den Daumen enthalten?
Ja, als Kind. Da war ich so 15, 13 Jahre alt.
Okay.
Okay, alles klar.
Und erleben Ihre Eltern noch?
Nein, sie sind beide gestorben.
War ein richtiges Beileid, da darf ich fragen,
woran sie gestorben?
Also die Mutter hatte Brustkrebs, ist gestorben.
Beim Vater hatte Nebazirose, ist dann auch gestorben.
Nebazirose?
Ja.
Schon ein paar Jahre her.
Aber Sie gehst schon bis da?
Nein, ich bin ein Einzelkind.
Einzelkind? Okay.
Ein bisschen fischer.
Welcher Beruf üben Sie aus?
Ich bin im Einzelhandel tätig.
Ich arbeite bei Rewe.
Verkäuferin?
Ja, Einzelhandelskaufmann.
Bei Rewe.
Ja.
Ich würde Sie fragen,
haben Sie Probleme auf Ihre Arbeit, die Sie belasten?
Also ich habe ein bisschen Probleme.
Also ich bin jetzt auch krankgeschrieben gewesen,
ich habe ein Mobbing-Problem auf der Arbeit.
Mobbing?
Okay.
Haben Sie schon darüber eine Unterstützung bekommen?
Noch nicht nein.
Okay.
Deswegen beginnt die Arbeit, sind Sie geschützt?
Kann man sagen?
Ja, das kann man sagen.
Okay, fischer.
Wie ist Ihre Familie nicht dann?
Ich bin geschieden.
Aber Sie Kinder?
Nein, haben keine Kinder.
Ich habe vergessen zu fragen, wie ist Ihre Appetit gerade?
Appetit?
Also aktuell ist es nicht so gut.
Okay.
Alles klar.
Okay, fischer.
Ich glaube, ich habe alle wichtigen Informationen gesammelt.
Gibt es noch etwas, das Sie mir sagen möchten?
Oder haben Sie noch Fragen?
Ja, was meinen Sie, Doktor, woran das kommen könnte?
Ach so, ich habe vergessen.
Ich komme gleich.
Nehmen Sie die gelbmäßigen Medikamente?
Also nur wegen dieser Arthrose habe ich das Dicklofenac, das ich nehme.
Wie viel Milligramm nehmen Sie?
Das ist 75 Milligramm.
Bei Bedder, nicht immer.
Nicht immer.
Okay.
Jetzt würde ich Sie über weitere Schritte informieren.
Sie sollten hier bleiben, bis ich Ihre Diagnose bestätigen kann.
Danach würde ich Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Und Ihre Herz- und Lung abholen und dann in die Blut abnehmen.
Und dann würde ich gerne, auftischall des Abdorms des Bauches,
durchführen und dann über Ihre Beschwerden besprechen.
Und dann haben wir eine Schriftel zusammen, was wir jetzt machen.
Was denken Sie, was das am ersten Fünftgrund hat?
Ich gehe von einer Ulkustoridone.
Das ist eine Entzündung der Söööööööööööfffinger-Darm.
Finger-Darm, okay.
Aber das ist nur eine Verdastdiagnose.
Ja.
Ja, nach der Ööööööööffinger-Darm.
Ja, bitte schön.
Wie kann man das dann feststellen, ob das das ist oder was anderes ist?
Anderes zum Beispiel, akutge-gasturentritis, die Entzündung der Dick-Darm oder Dünndarmus.
Oder akutge-apendicitis, aber nein, sie würden schon apendoptomiert.
Ja, ja.
Ja.
Und auch, wie kann man das behandeln?
Ja, Ihre Beschwerden sind natürlich behandelbar, heilbar.
Aber jetzt ist es so für mich, eine Medikamente zu verschreiben.
Zuerst müssen wir die Diagnose stellen.
Okay, okay.
Und die Diagnose stellen Sie denn mit Ultraschall oder Herr Doktor?
Ultraschall und Blutabnahme, ja, dabei körperliche Untersuchungen.
Okay, sonst braucht man nichts zu machen, oder?
Ja, ja.
Okay.
Ja, und vielen Dank und beantworten Sie bitte kurz im Wartezimmer.
Und sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ich bin geimpft, ja, auch gegen Covid.
Eigentlich ist es Covid.
Ja, ich frage nur, weil die Schwester, die mich aufgenommen hat eben gerade, die meine Personalien genommen hat,
und sie sagen, man muss auf jeden Fall eine Spiegelung machen.
Was denken Sie?
Ja, gegen einen Fall können wir Ihnen oder Sie eine Spiegelung des Magens,
ja, das heißt, unser Fall, unser Fall, das ist ein Endoskopie.
Ja.
Wir haben mit der Endoskopie, wir haben mit der Spiegelung, können wir Ihre Holorgane beurteilen,
ob alles in Ordnung ist oder nicht, oder gibt es eine Entzündung,
oder irgendetwas pathologische Befunde?
Okay.
Ich habe Angst davor, von dieser Spiegelung, muss ich sagen, ist das schmerzhaft, diese Spiegelung?
Die Spiegelung ist ein bisschen schmerzhaft, aber bei der Untersuchung geben wir Ihnen Schlafmittel
und dann verspüren Sie weniger Schmerz.
Okay, sind die Schmerzen im Hals oder im Bauch oder wo sind die Schmerzen bei der Spiegelung?
Besonders im Halsbereich, Schmerzen, wie Sie sehen.
Aber machen Sie sich keine Zauberbitte, weil das ist weniger, weil wir geben Ihnen ein Schmerz,
Betonmusmittel, Schlafmittel.
Ist es eine Vollnachrose, oder eine Doktor, oder was machen Sie dann?
Kursefristige Vollnachrose.
Vollnachrose, das ist auch gefährlich, oder eine Vollnachrose?
Aha, ja, nie, nicht gefährlich, weil vor der Untersuchung,
weil nicht gefährlich, weil Sie würden schon eine Operation durchgeführt.
Aber das war vor 40 Jahren, das Doktor, schon lange her.
Ja, aber das bedeutet, dass Sie gegen Medikament oder Betreuungsmittel nicht allergisch sind.
Das ist eine gute Sache für Sie.
Kann da etwas passieren bei dieser Endoskopie?
Bei der Endoskopie könnte zum Beispiel eine Belutung oder ein Trauma in der Hohlorgane passieren,
oder sein, aber das ist sehr selten.
Wir haben sehr Erfahrung mit der Untersuchung.
Kann da etwas platzen im Magen?
Ja, manchmal könnte es sein.
Können Sie wiederholen?
Kann der Magen auch platzen bei der Untersuchung?
Ach so, nie.
Ich lasse meinen Explorieren, oder?
Explodieren, ja.
Operation, oder?
Ja, kann das passieren?
Theoretisch, ja, könnte es passieren, aber ich habe nicht gehört.
Okay, kommt nicht so oft vor, hoffentlich, ja?
Ja, genau.
Und wie lange dauert Untersuchung?
Ist das eine große Operation, diese Spiegelung?
Ungefähr 30 Minuten.
Und auch durch diese Untersuchung, Spiegelung, können wir als sowohl diaktnotische Verfahren
als auch therapeutische Verfahren machen, durchführen.
Okay, das weiß man dann?
Zum Beispiel, bei der Untersuchung können wir eine Gewebe entnehmen,
d.h. eine Gewebe-Obsie, oder manchmal...
Das tut auch weh, oder?
Ein bisschen.
Aber, ja.
Okay, alles klar.
Und kann man das auch ohne Endeskopie behandeln,
meine Krankheit, oder muss es um Endeskopie sein, unbedingt?
Nicht unbedingt.
Vielleicht mit Ultraschall, oder die anderen Untersuchungen,
können wir Ihre Diagnose schon bestätigen.
Okay, alles klar, danke.
Gewebe-Obsie können wir eine Endeskopie behandeln.
Alles klar, okay, gut.
Okay, Doktor, dann machen Sie mal Ihre Arbeit, ich will Sie nicht zu sehr ablenken.
Alles klar.
Okay, danke schön.
So, gibt es noch weitere Fragen im Chat?
Moment, wo es hier Medikamente ist, hat er gefragt.
Magenspiegelung, Neugedäst, das Wiesn-Fagassupiniskopie,
Biobsie, Blutstille kann man machen, genau, HP.
Okay, das kann man als Diagnose machen,
bei der Endeskopie richtig.
Gut, in der Endeskopie tut nicht weh,
müssen Sie sagen den Patienten.
Nicht weh?
Nein, die Biopsy tut nicht weh, nein.
Wow.
Und auch eine Biobsie tut nicht weh, das merkt der Patient nicht, ja.
Also, normal Fall.
Okay, wollen Sie?
Darf ich eine Frage stellen?
Darf ich hören, ja.
Sie haben gesagt, dass die Schulter, Schulterarthrose und Kniearthrose haben.
Und dagegen nehmen Sie eine Diplopenach an.
Und gleichzeitig nehmen Sie auch eine Magenschutzmedikamente?
Bisher nicht, nein.
Okay, in der letzten Zeit nehmen Sie vielmein Medikamente,
diese Schmerzmutter.
Ja, war geholfen, ja.
Okay, danke schön.
Okay, wollen wir dann Oberarztvorstellung machen?
Klar, dann bitte schön.
Ja, hello.
Oberarzt, mein Name ist Enes Erdwöch.
Wenn Sie kurz Zeit hätten, würde ich gerne einen neuen Patientin vorstellen.
Gerne, bitte schön, ja.
Es geht um Herr Klaus Fischer, der 50 Jahre alt, 1,65 m groß, 75 kg schwer sei.
Er stellte sich bei uns seit einer Woche
dumpf und brennende Abdominalgie in der Mitte vor.
Die Schmerzen seien langsam aufgetreten.
Und dann haben die Patienten heute einmal Erbroschen.
Und der Erbroschen sei blutig und der Zieh hier dunkel aus.
Ja, und dem Patienten Folge liegt der Schmerz in der Intensität,
die Schmerzintensität auf einer Schmerzschmutter von 1 bis 10, 2, 7 und 8.
Und im Lauf der, der Patient sagte, dass die Schmerzen sich im Lauf der Zeit
verschlechtert haben.
Und es ist auffällig, dass die Schmerzinn sich,
dass die Schmerzinn nach dem Essen besser geworden sei.
Ja, und auch die Schmerzinn würden in den,
in den untenen Bauch ausstrahlen.
Das ist ein Ausstrahl.
Ja, und auch ist ihm übel, ein bisschen übel.
Und er leidet unter Innerpätenz.
Und die Frage nach Fibar, Schütterfrost, Gewichtsveränderung,
und Nachtschweiz wurden hernein.
Und Anvorerkrankungen, Leidene,
Kurz unterbrechung und Entschuldigung,
wenn ich kurz zusammenfassend habe, ob ich es richtig verstanden habe.
Also der Patient hat sich vorgestellt mit abdominellen Schmerzen,
mit Punktum Maximum im Mittelbauch,
die Leidene Unterbauch ausstrahlen.
Ja, ist richtig.
Und dann einmal erbrochen Blut, ich sagten Sie, war das frischblutig?
Hat der Blut gesehen, der Patient?
Ja.
Er sagte, dass der erboreschende Blut aufsteht.
Also frag nicht, ob der Hematin könnte sein.
Ja.
Aber kein frisches, rotes Blut, ja?
Ja, kein.
Okay, dann machen Sie weiter erstmal mit der Vorerkrankung.
Ja, und an Vorerkrankungen leidene er unter Colletocollitiasis,
seit neun Jahren, die nicht unbedingt behandelt werden müssten.
Also am ehesten ist Colletocollitiasis, ja, in den kalten Blasenstein.
Und auch er leidet unser Schulteratrose und Knieatrose.
Knieatrose oder Konatrose?
Aber Schulteratrose ist auch okay.
Schulteratrose und Konatrose.
Also Schulter und Knieatrose oder Omatrose und Konatrose?
Ja.
Und gleichzeitig seit sieben Jahren habe er Van Schalbe vorbeig.
Hat er mal gehabt vor zehn Jahren?
Hat er gehabt, ja.
Okay.
Vor sieben Jahren.
Ja.
Und auch, ja, und fernisch müsse der Patient an Schmerzen nachts aufwachen.
Und er stose seit Langem auf.
Aufstoss.
Und auch einmalig sei der Schütul dunkler geworden.
Ja, seine Schütulangebote.
Und beim Patienten sei Appendectomy als Kind durchgeführt worden.
Okay.
Und in der Familie der Nese fanden sich Mama Karcinom bei der Mutter und Leber Sirose bei dem Vater.
Und er habe keine Geschwister.
Und er nehme regelmäßige, er nehme die Klöpfung nach 75 Milligramm Beiber ein.
Ja.
Gegen Schmerzen, durch Schmerzen.
Und sie, er sei Verkäufer bei Revie.
Aber wegen der Arbeit und wegen der Mobbing habe er Stress.
Er sei gestresst.
Okay.
Und er sei gescheitert und habe keine Kinder.
Keine Kinder.
Ja.
Und er treibe keinen Sport.
Die an einem nächtlichen Angaben deuten auf, am Erste, auf eine Ulkustodone hin.
Dafür schieb ich vor allem Bauchschmerzen in der Mitte.
Audioplaminerge in der Mitte.
Und es ist auffällig, dass Essen, Linda schmerzen.
Okay.
und kein Fieber und auch Alkoholkonsum und Alkoholkonsum und Nikotinabus.
Das sind auch begünstigende Faktoren.
Genau, ein Discofaktor für Ulkustuodini.
Und Alternativ kommen.
Akutsu-Gaspränteritis, Akutopankreatis, Akutopandisitis,
Nino-Chin, Imprage.
Das sind die wichtigsten Fernseher Technosen.
Was sind denn die Komplikationen beim Ulkustuodini?
Perforation, Blutung, Neuepath.
Wenn es nach hinten geht, Penetration in den Pankpäs.
Perforation, Akutopandisitis, Nino-Chin, Nino-Chin, Nino-Chin, Nino-Chin.
Perforation, wenn es in der Brei-Bauchgülung ist,
in Studino muss man die Penetration beitragen,
damit es die Akutopandisis führen kann.
Was machen Sie mit den Patienten?
Die Patienten müssen nicht stationär aufgenommen werden.
Sondern ich verscheibe,
so werde ich den Patienten körperlich untersuchen
und dann Blutap nehmen.
Und danach, ja, gegen den Gebernfalls
kann ich auch Herz und Blumen abhören
und dann beim Geräusch abhören.
Das machen Sie auf jeden Fall.
Ja, wir haben recht.
Danach, natürlich, ich werde der ECHGK schreiben,
um eine Herzkrankheit auszuschließen,
weil ich zum Beispiel Hinterwand im Fallursach war auf Schmerzen.
Dann auch mal sein, richtig.
Und dann natürlich, ich möchte gerne,
ich möchte den Abdormen durchführen.
Was erwarten Sie da?
Warum machen Sie Urteile?
Ich erwarte gar nicht.
Oder ich würde gerne Blutgenprojekte durchverlassen,
um eine Freiluft im Abdormen zu geben.
Auszuschießen, ob eine Freiluft im Abdormen gibt oder nicht.
Dafür macht man aber kein Röntgen Torax.
Ja, Röntgen Torax.
Röntgen Torax macht man nicht, um freie Luft auszuschließen.
Für die freie Luft machen Sie ein Abdorbenübersicht.
Und meistens linksseitenlage.
Auf der Röntgen Torax können wir zum Beispiel
zwei Spell beurteilen, oder?
Richtig, können Sie, aber manchmal kann man auch.
Kann es auch, also ein Röntgen Torax
mit zum Ausstoß freie Luft
nicht die Indikation für einen Röntgen Torax.
Sie ist ein Abdorbenübersichter.
Aber Röntgen Torax können Sie auch machen?
Was wäre dann die Fragestellung?
Atmen.
Wenn Sie bei den Patienten einen Röntgen Torax machen,
was stellen Sie als Frage rein?
Röntgen Torax in zwei Beinen.
Ja, aber warum?
Zum Beispiel?
Was wollen Sie wissen?
Ich möchte wissen, ob zum Beispiel
es eine Infektration in der Lunge gibt,
oder zum Beispiel die Lobberpneumonie
vielleicht auch verursacht.
Genau, Pneumonie ist eine Fragestellung.
Also eine Basalepneumonie kann man auch beurteilen.
Ich möchte auch zum Beispiel beurteilen.
Richtig, also es ist vielleicht eine große Herne,
die Sie beurteilen können.
Und natürlich können Sie auch, wenn Sie Glück haben,
auch in einer Perforation sehen mit freie Luft.
Aber dafür ist die spezielle Fragestellung,
mit einem Abdorbenübersicht zu stellen.
Gut.
Und jetzt haben Sie Urtaschall gesagt,
warum machen Sie Urtaschall?
Was wollen Sie da beurteilen?
Urtaschall, damit ich eine freie Wasser feststellen kann.
Bei der Perforation gibt es
Freie Wasser, oder?
Freie Fristigkeit im Bau.
Okay, ja.
Das wäre eine Frage, oder Sie können auch andere Organe mit beurteilen.
Genau, Leber, Nieren, oder?
Gut, jetzt haben Sie Blut abgenommen.
Patient hat HB von 8.
Was machen Sie jetzt mit ihm?
HB, ehemalige Lobben von 8.
Ah, okay, dann das bedeutet, der patient blutet.
Weil, das ist der Mann, und dann wir denken, ja.
Und das ist der Blut,
dafür spricht das,
das spricht für eine Perforation vielleicht.
Nein, ich muss sagen, ich kann ja auch normal Blutung in die,
in den, in den, in den, in den Magen oder in den Dordion sein.
Es könnte eine Blutung in der hohen Organe sein.
Das ist das häufigste, ja.
Weil sein Erbruchchen sieht blutig, dunkel aus.
Könnte Herr Martin sein, ja.
Und was machen Sie dann? Dann nehmen Sie sich stationär auf, oder?
Und dann natürlich, ja.
Dann müssen wir den Patienten sich stationär aufnehmen
und dann einen Doskokie machen.
Okay, alles klar.
Was ist denn die häufigste Ursache
für, für Ulkusskrankheit, Magen, Darm?
Alkohol, Alkoholkonsum,
Nikotin, Abkonsum.
Was noch?
Scharf und Würstiges, vielleicht, oder nicht?
Okay.
Manche allergens Ursa,
Ulkussdordene oder Nene, okay.
Ja selten, aber es sind so,
also, das Einnahmen sind glaub ich schon genannt, oder?
Medikamente, ja.
Ja, ja, ja, nicht zu reden.
Genau, das ist ein riesiger Kopakter.
Ja, stimmt.
Und dann gibt es noch eine andere Ursache für Ulkusskrankheit
oder Gastritissen in…
Gallenstein, Gallenstein.
Einstein nicht, nee, das ist noch.
Hat jemand schon den Chat geschrieben gerade?
Hab nicht, ich bin…
Helikopakter, ja.
Ach so, Helikopakter-Kategorie, ja.
Kann Ursache sein, dann müssen sie halt, ja.
Deswegen würde man bei diesen Patienten,
mit diesen Beschwerden in der Regel auch den sowieso endoskopieren, glaub ich, ja.
Also, diesen Patienten können endoskopiert,
damit es zu wenigstens auch mal Helikopakter aufstiehen,
zumal auch an anamnästisch auch so ein Brinn und so was angeben hat.
Das kann ja so eine,
eine Gastrodentale Krankheit sein,
Ulkusskrankheit sein, die er hat, ja.
Okay, gut, prima.
Sonst noch irgendwelche Vorschläge,
dann die Therapie abhängig davon, was sie ein Problem haben.
Endoskopisch können sie Blutstille,
können sie Proben nehmen,
wie ob es jedenfalls Ulkuss ist,
damit sie wissen, ob es bösartig ist.
Sind Ulzerer im Doordinnum oft bösartig,
oder eher nicht gutartig?
Bösartig.
Nee, im Ulk, im Doordinnum sind sie eher gutartig,
im Magen können sie eher bösartig sein.
Im Doordinnum selten, ja.
Ja, aber wenn zum Beispiel nicht abhalten,
müssen sie auch da Biopsten machen, ja.
Ja, natürlich.
Okay, und sonst ein Helikopakter-Test,
können sie theoretisch auch ohne Endoskopie machen,
da hat jemand ja schon geschrieben,
gab den Atemtest, ja.
Per Perchmetri.
Per Perchmetri nicht,
es gibt einen Atemtest, wo sie halt den,
den Krimi-Patienten was schlucken,
und dann kann man den Stoffwechsel messen,
die CT, ich weiß auch gar nicht, wie der heißt,
der CT-12-Atemtest, ja.
Wo man dann messen kann,
auch die Patienten für die Helikopaktor-Infektion haben.
Wäre eine nichtinvasive Methode für Helikopakternachweis.
Man kann auch Antigenachweis im Stuhl, glaube ich,
man aber ist sicher, es ist natürlich Biopsy, ja.
Gut, okay, und dann abhängig davon,
medikamentöse Behandlungen, was gibt man da
bei Ulkuss-Krankheit oder bei Ulzara im Magen
12-Fingerdamen, welche Medikamente gerne?
Proton von Hamar, die Medikamentöse,
um auf Plausenlande, Plausenlande.
Und wenn sie Helikopakte haben, machen sie was?
Dann müssen wir die Helikopakte-Erdikation
erredikieren, erredikieren.
Ja, es gibt auch verschiedene Methoden,
für die Helikopakte-Erdikation.
Okay, gut, gibt es noch Kommentare oder Fragen
aus dem Chat?
Das hat man nahe, C13-Atems ist genauer, das war es.
Ich glaube, das Wichtigste haben wir gesagt.
Anamese war auch soweit okay.
Was gefehlt? Keine Kommentare. Diät, ja.
Was für eine Diät?
Einschulung für die Patientin, damit er
zum Beispiel die gesundliche Ernährung
sich ernehren kann.
Weniger Alkohol, weniger Nekotin und dann mehr.
Das ist das Hauptproblem, glaube ich.
Das ist ein Kammernernährungs-Seraport.
Magst du schon und essen?
Ja, genau, vielleicht schon.
Stressvermeiden ist auch immer gut, wenn es geht.
Alkohol, Nekotin, Aposos, Abstellen, ja,
das sind alles gute Sachen.
Alles klar, okay.
Vielen Dank für das Gespräch.
Vielen Dank, war aber ein ganzes, ein guter Anamese
und auch gutes Gespräch.
Ich habe extra so ein bisschen gefragt, damit man
aus diesen Textbausteinen rauskommt,
dass sie flexibel sind.
Das kann sein, dass sowas in der Prüfung auch kommt,
damit die merken, ob sie auch frei sprechen können.
Das ist wichtig und das haben sie gut gemacht.
Okay, beginnt die Bucher da los.